con solo una maleta y a veces su mascota
estos ucranianos emprenden el camino al
exilio así como estas familias que
esperan en el pasillo de una estación de
tren en el sureste de polonia tres
millones de personas han huido del país
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa un
éxodo rápido y masivo que no tiene
precedentes
tanto para la migración interna como
para el movimiento de refugiados es una
de las migraciones más importantes que
hemos visto en todo el continente
europeo y ciertamente incluso en todo el
mundo
sin entrar como hemos visto la
destrucción fue muy importante las
necesidades también son muy importantes
si eres del suelo los hombres que
cuentan con edad para defender el país
no pueden salir de ucrania por lo tanto
la mitad de estos refugiados son niños
una población especialmente vulnerable
ha visto cada post 11 lógicas de
explotación y trata de solucionar un
riesgo muy importante es el riesgo de
explotación y trata de personas
explotación en todas sus formas de
explotación sexual para cometer delitos
trabajos forzados obligación a mendigar
y también está el riesgo para los niños
de desaparición luego es que por eso les
pague el 60% de estos refugiados se
encuentra actualmente en polonia pero
para algunos es sólo una etapa hay
centros de acogida más al oeste en
berlín o en parís en las últimas tres
semanas al menos 18.000 personas que
huyen de la guerra en ucrania han
llegado a francia